on n'a jamais eu le temps de problème
que ça c'est un gars qui était bosseur
il voulait que ça réussir juste cette
année il a il a eu tous ces trucs il a
passé ses super lourd il a eu il a eu
son BPA il a tout eu
après pour ma part pour les incendies
qui s'est passé
il a eu un bracelet certes on sait pas
comment c'est fini l'histoire
donc il avait un bracelet un moment il
avait embrasser électronique et je le
connaissais pas tant que ça cette époque
là d'accord mais on le saviez dans la
région qu'il avait un bracelet
ça se savait un peu mais voilà après il
était
quoi quand vous avez appris que Lucas
était impliqué dans cette affaire ça a
été quoi votre réaction vous êtes dit
oui ça m'étonne pas ou vous êtes dit
impossible pas Lucas moi par ma part dès
que je suis la disparition de Justine
je sais pas c'est un j'ai pensé à lui
tout de suite quand vous avez vu la
photo du site ouais j'ai pensé à lui
tout de suite
faut savoir que ils étaient pas des
inconnus
on a déjà fait des expériences ensemble
d'accord il se connaissent ils se
connaissaient déjà parlé sur
instantage
c'était pas des inconnus
est-ce que vous avez appelé les parents
de de justice que vous avez essayé de
les joindre parce que c'est vrai que
toute la France était extrêmement
inquiète et parce que vous avez tous
essayé de la contacter sur Instagram
parce que moi je la connais
je la connais pas tant que ça mais je la
connais un peu de bar
après on se voyait qu'on se voyait on se
racontait un peu notre vie on se papoter
faut soyez pas tous les jours on soyez
peut-être une fois ou deux fois par
trois fois par mois quand il venait
Lucas donc il se voyait il se voyait
souvent
la relation mais
en boîte
meurtre cadavres
quand vous avez entendu ça de quelqu'un
que vous connaissez
toujours que ça arrive qu'aux autres
vous êtes dit quoi il est devenu fou ou
il a toujours été fou c'est une durite
il a dû des Boulonnais
c'est une explicable c'est une
explicable c'est pas inexplicable
il avait jamais eu de comportement
violent particulièrement avant ou jamais
jamais jamais
c'est pas le bagarreur en soirée quoi
c'est pas le mec qui va [ __ ] c'est le
mec bonbon ou de toujours à vouloir
s'amuser
il avait des sentiments pour Justine ou
pas ce qui je sais pas je pense pas
parce que nous et c'est vrai qu'il y a
on avait encore un espoir aujourd'hui
les espoirs sont
effondrées on pense forcément la famille
du film mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit
quand j'ai vu la photo de persuadé
meurtrier présumé je suis sûr que tous
les gens qui ont vu la photo sont dit
mais
on a envie de voilà c'est c'est vrai
qu'on se dit si alors c'est bête de dire
ça mais on se dit c'est vrai que voilà
il a l'air tellement on se dit voilà il
allait c'est monsieur tout le monde
exactement
ça c'est monsieur tout le monde il est
sociable il est très facilement sociable
c'est pas le gars qui a le portefeuille
dans la poche à pas vouloir aider
quelqu'un vous étiez quelqu'un de
sociable vous étiez là dans cette soirée
ou pas non non moi je l'ai laissé d'une
certaine heure après je suis pas resté
toute la soirée et vous étiez avec lui
au départ au départ de soirée oui au
départ de soirée oui il avait bu on
avait on avait bu un peu on avait bu on
était déjà c'est un samedi soir
et vous disait quoi lors de la soirée il
était normal rien à dire tout le monde
se retrouvait on se pose au bar et
voilà après moi je l'ai laissé quand il
est parti à charrette moi du coup je
suis rentré si j'étais fatigué
et après
de ce jour là quand vous avez vu
la photo du style est-ce que vous avez
essayé de
l'appeler tout de suite où il a ce qu'il
a toujours il a tout de suite été
interpellé aussi ce que vous avez eu ce
que vous avez essayé de joindre ou à
joindre ses parents parce que je me suis
dit
quand j'ai juste photos je me suis dit
ça et
j'ai pas prêté attention je me suis dit
non
Lucas après avoir longtemps nier tous
les soupçons des enquêteurs Lucas a
reconnu avoir tué Justine il a aussi
avoué avoir violé la jeune fille il y a
aussi révélé avoir enterré son corps
dans un bois dans une zone située près
de chez lui
et après des vérifications de cette zone
le corps de Justine a été retrouvé à
l'issue de sa garde à vue Lucas a été
présenté un juge en vue de sa mise en
examen
on peut pas on peut pas nier c'est pas
bien ce qu'il a fait tout on sait pas ce
qui s'est passé
on sait pas s'il était sous droit c'est
pas le gars qui prenait de la drogue et
tout
on sait pas ce qu'il y a eu
vous étiez avec lui au début de la
soirée
imaginé un instant que quelques heures
après
commettrait jamais
une différence entre être un peu
agressif impulsif et tuer une personne
quand même il a déjà été agressif
impulsif pas avec moi particulièrement
mais bon c'était quand même moi je l'ai
été aussi au collège assez agité tout ça
c'était un gars d'agité pas plus pas
moins
quand même avec un tempérament parfois
qui est décrit comme un comme un caïd
quelqu'un rebelle à l'autorité qui
n'aimait pas être contredit vous l'avez
vous l'avez constaté ça ce côté impulsif
moi étant jeune après étant plus vieux
je l'ai un peu moins qu'on côtoyait mais
étant jeune c'est vrai qu'il avait ce
côté un peu impulsif quand même
selon l'Agence France Presse après avoir
tué la jeune femme le dimanche matin il
serait allé rejoindre son équipe de foot
participer à un match de foot comme si
tout était normal ça paraît fou est-ce
que ça c'est le Lucas que vous
connaissez est-ce que vous imaginez que
l'ami vous avez a été capable de faire
ça non
vous nous en apprenez une
c'est comme si c'était une autre
personne en fait mais totalement
il s'est passé ça mais après il a
rejoint une autre personne le soir même
mais c'est ça puisque il faut rappeler
Gilles qu'est-ce qu'il a fait parce que
il est retourné
encore une autre fille
comme si rien s'était passé et alors il
a effacé les traces de sang voilà il a
pour les procureur a expliqué
aujourd'hui lors d'une d'un point presse
que donc il a avoué avoir tué la jeune
femme Justine chez lui
après il y a une variation il plaide
aujourd'hui un rapport sexuel consenti
la police dit viol et lui dire consenti
il l'aurait tué d'un coup de poing il
aurait tué d'un coup de poing alors que
des traces d'armes contendante ont été
retrouvées mais il dit l'avoir tué d'un
coup de poing et l'avoir enterré à
l'aide d'un engin agricole en lisière
d'un bois comme ça plus avoir effacé les
traces c'est un acte c'est c'est
terrible horrible
ça vaut qu'est-ce que ça nous comment
vous réagissez ça nous chamboule c'est
vous savez on est 1300 habitants dans ce
village ça tourne très très vite chez
une personne qui est facile une famille
quand même assez connue
très respectable très très respectable
et enfin
c'est un village en deuil franchement
enfin on sait pas quoi dire on sait pas
quoi penser enfin c'est très spécial
l'atmosphère c'est
très difficile pour les deux côtés de
famille oui mais plus
d'un côté ils ont perdu leur fille qui
était maman d'un enfant de 2 ans oui
mais de l'autre côté ton fils ceinture
c'est ça
c'est très difficile
mais de l'autre côté une famille
dévastée à vie par là par la par la
disparition
elle avait une petite fille
dont elle avait la garde un petit garçon
exactement
qui disait dès qu'on a vu la photo de
Justine on a pensé à lui à lui on a
pensé à Lucas c'est incroyable ça parce
que pourquoi en fait parce que c'est
vrai que vous disiez il va y avoir un
problème un jour il va il va parce que
c'est vrai qu'on c'est dingue je sais
pas je sais pas du tout pourquoi je
pensais ça je me serais le dire
et
moi pour ajouter quelque chose c'est
j'en reviens est-ce qu'on dit 1300
habitants on se dit jamais que n'importe
quelle personnalité va pouvoir réussir à
faire ça parce qu'il faut avoir quand
même un certain sang-froid
très gros sang-froid même vous qui le
connaissiez bien vous vous le
reconnaissez dans dans j'avais la vie je
pense un meurtre non on parle d'un
meurtre là quand même
je veux dire non il a enterré le corps
ensuite de très lourd il faut avoir un
très bon mental enfin faut c'est le type
de mec qui fait qui fait de mal à
personne
c'est aucun problème
il séparation agriculteurs il était à
fond dans ça
il était à fond dans ses bêtes c'était
[Musique]
quoi je l'ai déjà suivi je l'ai déjà
suivi à la fermer tout il y aura dans le
pré tu as tous les animaux qui viennent
qui viennent à pied qui qui alors on dit
qu'il avait eu des problèmes aussi avec
ses anciens employeurs oui
un hangar qui serait celui d'un ancien
patron encore une fois avec ce côté
oui alors voilà il y en a peut-être
exactement il y en aurait peut-être
d'autres on parle de deux ou trois quand
il était un peu plus jeune
éventuellement aussi on commence à en
parler ça il avait évoqué ça avec vous
il vous avait dit oui j'ai mis le feu à
hangar il parlait de ses travers
je pense qu'il a toujours nié voire
mille-feu il a toujours une femme
même avec vous
ça c'est sûr est un certain je l'ai
jamais entendu de sa voix
par exemple c'est lui visiblement alors
on parle de plus en plus d'un aussi de
quelqu'un qui avait un problème avec le
feu parce qu'il a brûlé les sacs de
Justin également il avait brûlé des
hangars pour se venger ces anciens
employeurs ça vous vous le saviez ça ou
pas du tout non qu'est-ce qui vous
disait sur l'affaire des hangars par
exemple vous en avez déjà parlé
à l'extérieur il voulait pas trop en
parler vous savez c'est pas un sujet que
j'ai eu invoquer après moi je
fréquentais pas trop à cette époque là
quand ça s'est passé
c'est pas trop un truc
je sais pas ce qui a donné l'enquête
mais il avait fait du mandat de dépôt en
Corrèze il y avait déjà été suivi je
pense par des personnes oui Delphine ces
dernières années dans sa vie
sentimentale est-ce qu'il avait
quelqu'un ou c'était quoi sa relation
aux femmes il sera plus à même de vous
répondre ces dernières années là quand
il y a une histoire des feux et tout il
fricotait avec quelqu'un mais ces
histoires ça
moitié fin il a rencontré une fille
que ça se ça se passait bien au début
c'était tout rose ils avaient un
appartement ensemble ils ont pris un
appartement ensemble
et
à la fin il s'enlacés à la fin ils sont
là c'est
[Musique]
il faut savoir que cette personne
n'était pas facile aussi
il était là il était il était
célibataire là il était célibataire là
c'est
plus avec et vous parlez du style
parfois ou pas du tout
oh non on en a parlé de nous deux fois
quand on la voyait il disait quoi
si tu le voyais bien en boîte il dansait
ensemble
c'est même les médias qui m'ont appris
qu'elle avait un copain
d'accord et quand il est
si vous l'aviez vu pour avoir il est
suivi il était déjà parti avec elle
voilà au cours de soirée elle est
Justine elle est célibat je risque rien
avec lui ah oui tu es déjà parti avec
lui
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que au jour d'aujourd'hui
je comprends pas
pourquoi ça a fini comme ça
je sais pas si ce sont
c'est pas c'est quelque chose ils ont
disputer peut-être il a paniqué ou
peut-être elle est tombée
il a paniqué c'est pour ça qu'il a réagi
comme ça
on sait pas c'est
tel que vous le connaissez un refus de
la part de Justine aurait pu susciter
chez lui une réaction de colère
d'impulsivité de violence quoi
la façon qui nous en a parlé déjà
aux policiers aux enquêteurs il aurait
dit quoi alors quel est le mode motif
la grande question c'est le mobile c'est
un rapport sexuel consenti et puis un
coup de poing et après panique je
l'enterre alors je l'enterre avec un
engin là on est plus dans la panique on
est dans l'action volontaire concerté
j'efface les traces donc là pareil une
volonté de l'organisme il disait qu'il
était sous la contrainte d'une autre
personne oui alors il y a ça aussi le
départ il a dit ça lui il dit à un
moment que j'ai été obligé de de faire
ça parce que quelqu'un était là derrière
moi pour le moment c'est le seul mis en
cause il est mis en examen pour meurtre
séquestration et viol donc il y a pas de
tierce personne apparaissant est-ce que
alors par rapport à la soirée ce que
vous avez vu vous quelqu’un d’autre
est-ce que la thèse d'un message il est
revenu là-dessus il a dit que c'était
voilà il est revenu là dessus juste
c'est vrai que beaucoup de gens qui vous
découvrent ce soir et qui disent bien
entendu on est complètement d'accord
avec eux qui disent parce que vous dites
voilà
il se connaissait bien ils avaient déjà
une petite aventure entre etc bien sûr
je me fais votre avocat c'est pas pour
ça bien sûr que vous dites ça peut
justifier ou excuser un viol ou un
meurtre ou juste vous revenez bien sûr
sur sur l'affaire et sur les relations
entre Justine et
ils sont meurtriers
Lucas mais c'est vrai bien sûr ça
n'excuse en rien mais c'est juste pour
savoir que pour faire comprendre de
téléspectateurs que vous vous saviez
qu'ils se connaissaient déjà bien donc
c'est juste pour montrer aussi que
Justine à mon avis elle était partie on
a vu son père hier il disait Justine et
naïve mais là et il l'a dit le
témoignage de son papa hier était
poignant et là elle a dû se dire voilà
je connais bien ce jeune homme en fait
voilà j'ai déjà vu on a déjà fait des
soirs ensemble donc là voilà j'ai aucun
risque au contraire elle s'est dit je
peux pas me méfier vous dites que vous
êtes dans un village de 1300 habitants
tout le monde se connaît et c'est vrai
qu'il y a on se dit c'est incroyable
comme vous êtes quand même vous avez dit
c'est incroyable que ça nous arrive dans
notre village un gars qu'on connaît tout
le monde se connaît la famille est
respectable c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un c'est pris un énorme coup sur
la tête complètement complètement on va
toujours penser à la famille du style à
Justine pendant des des
dans quel état alors
choc encore
foutu
c'est
vraiment c'est mon point de vue mais moi
je pense qu'il y a quelque chose d'autre
derrière il y a pas que ça jamais de la
vie surtout surtout sur Justine c'est
alors je vous dis là aujourd'hui nous on
peut pas non on peut pas entendre ça
aujourd'hui en direct excusez-moi vous
dites aujourd'hui on voit ces Custines
et
n'est plus là juste il est morte il a
avoué il est prévu mais visiblement il a
avoué mais aujourd'hui voilà
aujourd'hui il y a aucun
on peut pas voilà on peut lui trouver
aucune circonstances
je vous dis moi pour l'instant il y a
pas quelque chose en tout cas ce qu'on
voit et ce qu'on apprend aujourd'hui
c'est que pour l'instant c'est quelqu'un
qui est qui a commis un meurtre horrible
et on espère voilà que l'enquête va
avancer assez vite
justement Marc Rolland ils veulent que
ça traîne il y en a ils veulent pas que
ça aille vite il y a des gens
apparemment ils veulent pas que les
enquêtes aillent vite tu vois des
dernièrement on a entendu des gens des
sur plein de plein de tweets laisser
faire la justice il faut que ça prenne
le temps faut que ça prenne un an faut
que ça prenne 2 ans faut que ça prenne 3
ans et les parents et les familles
pendant 3 ans ils attendent les réponses
à chaque fois que ça sort du tribunal
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent les parents on
est content parce qu'on va enfin pouvoir
faire notre deuil alors moi j'en ai
marre des gens qui te disent on a Lola
là on a juste une on a des mecs qui
s'amusent à tuer des femmes comme ça
comme si c'était gratuit en plus il est
tu en plus il les enterre là il dit ou
il est le corps est présumé innocent je
veux bien mais il a quand même dit où
était le corps donc si c'est pas lui qui
dit ce qui c'est le plus rapidement
possible mais si c'est lui c'est ma
classe sortent de la vie tout seul moi
c'est mecs là ils se sortent de la vie
tout seul il a 21 ans on va lui mettre
quoi 20 ans 25 ans il sort il sort à 50
ans et il revient à 50 ans voilà voilà
c'est toujours le même problème c'est
toujours le même bordel il risque quoi
tu es cette femme qui a tué cette femme
et qui a violé cette femme qui fait des
demandes de liberté en ce moment parce
que la loi d'Orient et il fait des
demandes quand même il aura une peine de
sucre
tous ces mecs là tous ces mecs là qui
s'amusent à tuer gratuitement les Lola
qui mettent des gens c'est à faut
arrêter là c'est bon faut arrêter ça
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours on a des trucs comme ça c'est bon
marque Roland quand vous entendez ça
vous dites quoi mais je sens de
l'émotion de la colère mais il faut
comprendre aussi que le système
judiciaire peut-être qu'il est en France
a besoin de travailler dans l'apaisement
dans l'enquête on peut comprendre moi ce
que disait c'était les procès rapides
pour ça voilà qu'on est en procès rapide
mais et l'enquête voilà ADN ça y est
c'est très vite d'ailleurs là sur ce que
comme vous avez dit et il va là on sait
ce qui va se passer pour lui il va avoir
une peine de sûreté de dedans s'il est
reconnu coupable perpétuité avec une
peine de sûreté de 22 ans c'est ce qu'il
attend en tout cas c'est Éric c'est
encore un drame qui était qui est arrivé
et on pense très fort à la famille de de
Justine mais surtout au petit bien sûr
et surtout à toute sa famille au petit
sa famille à ses parents le père
[Musique]
le père est pas présent
non ça va être compliqué c'est de la
peine ça fait de la peine pour ce petit
Justine est venue pour s'amuser passer
une bonne soirée un tattoo dit alors
c'est ça qu'elle a fait de moi elle est
sortie danser c'est tout voilà
exactement
ça finit comme ça